a single women making nowadays with with
relationships or just in general well
just in general because like the
marriage rate is so low now like it's
lower than it's ever been so you know
women think that they men they think
that they can do the same thing as men
they think that they can have as just as
many bodies they think that they can
sleep with just as many people and not
have the same effect because see like a
guy a guy can sleep with a chick and are
we not talking about the dudes that get
emotionally attached right but we can we
can sleep with a chicken not even
remember your name the minute that we
have post clarity
like the very millisecond the mindset
can be now how do I get her out of here
you know what I'm saying like it doesn't
have to be an emotional attachment now a
woman in a lot of instances she can't
because she's being inserted right you
can't unsee and not take with you all of
the dudes that and and how that dude
affected you into a relationship so they
think that they can just do the same
thing as men and not be affected when in
reality
you are because you really carry in all
of this trauma and all of this stuff
that comes along with being in a
previous relationship and every other
relationship and she can't see it even
if it's subconscious she can't see the
experiences that she's already had so
you can't operate like a man do you guys
think
do you think that women
um I wonder it's hard I don't remember
it was like dude women fall in love oh
yeah
like or two women fall in love for like
a guy that's more of a provider or a guy
that just offers good
I think nowadays
women get blinded by good and they think
it's love but it's not have you seen the
Titanic women always been doing this
yeah for sure
the notebook I think the idea is when
you have both then you're really in love
then it's game over Lord knows I've
advertised but
it does not lead to a sustainable
relationships you've ever been but you
don't want to know oh no I do I do right
in the mic I was so hypnotized that uh
first of all we broke up 20 times in one
year I would go back and be like please
take me back I was such a little you'd
pop up
hypnotized he was like you have to wear
a mask and come over so I'd come over
after the drive during the pandemic he'd
be like you couldn't come near me
without a mask so I would mask up and
he'd be like suck my dick okay and I
would take the mask off and then I put
the mask back on and I would ride his
[ __ ] sunset with a mask on
yeah so I'm hypnotized no no where is he
now is he still in the picture he is
sending me pics trying to get me back
and like progress photos of his workouts
yeah oh okay he can get her if you want
her
I think the biggest thing was that it
wasn't them had toxic behaviors and both
so that was not allowing them to have
like to grow their connection and they
need time apart to heal that I don't
know I was just thinking why why he
blocked he could have her
yeah that's a good point oh that's true
you didn't block him I didn't know I did
tell you to block him he's never gonna
block him
the door's got to be open a little bit
he can get her he can get her tomorrow
if he wanted her
fun fact about Emily and I'm gonna put
you on the Emily's been for over a year
and a half since that boyfriend
wow I'm gonna ask no that's what they
said that the women get their hearts
broke and then they go yeah yeah I did
it for eight months after like my
dramatic relationship and I think that
completely changed the game for me
emotionally of like growing as a woman
because I definitely was
the girl who used almost like in my body
to feel validated by men like that was
the only way I'd feel close to somebody
and I misconstrued it for what it was
but being said it has like allowed me to
like okay who is this man for real you
talk about like marriage being like a
business I used to just be like in love
and be like okay I love you let's get
married and have babies but if there
wasn't things that I was thinking about
ahead of time that would make sure that
it was a fulfilling long-term
relationship how can you decide though
that it's fulfilling long-term
relationship with the guy
is not having sex because if the guy is
worth anything and he's not having sex
he's not going to stay with you right oh
this isn't like we're not having someone
we're with men this is when we weren't
dating if I'm with my man
he's gonna be taken care of him
right yeah yeah it's like I think part
of the being said a bit too is like I
was spending time dating and I
was having and I was having sex with the
wrong people and like when they weren't
like showing me they deserved it as much
and from that there
I mean like they were still taking care
of silly but
the relationship building blocks were
not there how does a guy show that he
deserve it
um I think you can kind of tell now I'm
able to tell when a man is a little bit
more serious it's like how they reach
out to you how they respect you are they
opening doors are they introducing you
to meet their family are they but are
they doing that like at the right time
they're like hey it's important for
someone to meet my Mom they're not just
letting everyone meet their mom you know
what I mean
um their values and what they're working
on there's a lot of aspects it's pretty
nuanced that's the determining factor
for whether or not you guys or it's just
like if he's relationship material
why don't you tell us what do you think
I mean I don't
everybody I mean other people got it
already though
what do you mean so you think a woman
should sleep with a man right away
why should I wait well you don't have to
wait but are you gonna respect the woman
the same amount respect or how
it's an equal extent you getting
somebody that's just like I am so if you
want a girl to be like that relationship
material should she wait to have sex
with you
well I mean but you've already you've
already given it away yeah it's like
it's like insulting to guys if you make
them wait but you didn't make the last
like you let them have last five hit
like I want the same thing that the last
guy got it's kind of like the way the
way I make it as an equivalent is like
if a dude I don't know bought you a
let's just say a hundred dollar gift and
then you found out the year before he
planned his girlfriend a whole surprise
party and got her Louie and all this
stuff yeah and you'd be like like first
you're happy with the gift you're like
oh I got this great gift and then you
find out that's what he did for the last
girl and you're like I feel like a lot
of men don't appreciate things they
don't work for though as much and like
women Bond through having sex like that
hormones released but men bond in the
time of like they're not having sex and
getting to know somebody then they have
sex and they're a little bit more locked
in because they've taken the time to get
to know someone versus when you just hit
it right away you're like well I already
got what I was looking for and you're
not taking that time to like fully
invest in something I think I think
you're right I just think like to a lot
of times to guys it's it's just
insulting to them if you let the guy a
guy before have sex right away and then
later you make someone else I mean
because we already know yeah that you
let the guy or at least previous guys so
what about what if
um so for me personally the guys who
I've had sex with they have had to wait
so do you think that moving forward I
should just have something have you had
a lot of guys no they had to wait like
I think like
because when I was much younger as I've
gotten older I think it's the time has
speak okay like the last guy the last
guy he wait
he waited probably two months two three
months around there too
man this guy wait two three months I'm
just let me get this job and you said
wait
well she's young right so I think 24. oh
oh okay sure baby wait as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible